a chaotic scene at a vaccination center
in the tunisian capital
impatient crowds have tried to force
their way through to get covered 19
vaccines
for me it's mandatory it's a vaccine
covetous a serious disease
and personally it scares me
[Music]
i've come here for a third time you wait
a long time and then you go without
getting a vaccine
it's not normal that there is only one
vaccination center in a state
look at all the people why all of this
what have we done
you authorities if you cannot find
solutions for us let us search for
solutions for ourselves
this followed a highly controversial
decision by the ministry of health
to provide vaccines for everyone above
the age of 18 at the same time
it has led to stamp feeds at nine
vaccination centers across the country
raising fears of a sharp rise in
infection rates
prime minister hisham meshishi fired his
health minister for what he described
as a clear case of mismanagement
the least that can be said is that the
decision is wrong and you have noticed
its repercussions on society
tunisia continues to face some of the
highest coveted 19 infection rates in
the world
its rank in third after ecuador and
namibia
with about 200 deaths a day according to
official medical sources
nearly 18 000 people have died in a
country of 12 million
many hospitals have run out of beds and
oxygen
medical staff are overwhelmed there are
reports of patients
dying in the absence of proper care and
bodies staying
unburied for days
we've had daily surges we even had 50
patients at the same time in our covered
unit at the farhad hashed emergency room
in soos
while our maximum capacity varies
between 18 to 20 patients
you know doctors are losing hope in the
whole tunisian health system
everyone is losing hope but we're here
for our patients
we try to do our best for them as cases
continue to soar
everyone seems to want to be the first
to get the vaccine
but with limited stocks fewer than a
million have received the two jobs so
far
that's about eight percent of the
tunisian population
the situation here has triggered
solidarity and fears across north africa
with neighboring libya closing its
border and other arab countries sending
medical supplies
to help prevent a humanitarian disaster
mohammed